I've got you know I just did a quick
Google search Texas Senate committee
heard legislation on Monday aiming to
prohibit social media platforms from
censoring users based on their
viewpoints
Senate Bill SB 12 filed by Senator Brian
Hughes of Mineola let's uh pop this open
see what we got here introduced senate
committee report and grossed
uh I don't know what any of that means
I'll have to look into this
but uh I gotta be honest like we gotta
we got a big operation going on here
here's the thing though if Texas offers
up these protections we have no choice
but to move there you know why
my business could be shut down overnight
yeah these platforms could just nuke us
overnight
everybody loses their jobs
go to Texas we have recourse I would
have no choice if this bill passes to do
that
well I guess I'll need to move too I
guess we'll all need to move I think I
think most people would go to Texas I
mean I you know there is interesting
things about DC with um
you know political Viewpoint political
party or affiliation is a protected
class but that doesn't do anything about
big Tech no I don't think so I mean and
this is what you know the funny thing is
I remember two years ago I've been
advocating for exactly this type of law
I was hoping we'd get it done at the
federal level but man if we can get at
the state level and and you know we get
some friendly judges who look at it the
same way Thomas does right Federal
preemption of a state-created speech
right
that would be I mean that's fascinating
I mean and because that would basically
it honestly it would have to I think you
know Twitter and Facebook and YouTube
would probably at that point stop
censoring everybody because they
wouldn't they went on a risk somebody
being in Texas and having a cause of
action but but wouldn't uh so let's say
you're in Texas they pass this bill you
know they pass this it becomes law the
governor signs it you get censored and
so you immediately go into a court file
the paperwork or whatever you what would
you say you file an injunction so you so
you file a you know I mean you file a
complaint right that's yeah any lawsuit
begins with a complaint and then you
also file a motion for a preliminary
injunction which gives you your accounts
back right like if you win that motion
you get your account back
um that could be really quickly couldn't
it yeah I mean injunctions can get heard
very fast like sometimes there's like
temporary restraining orders that are
super fast
um but then a preliminary injunction can
happen you know you can get a decision
on that within weeks if you want so so
let me ask let's say I'm in Texas and
we're doing the show and then one one
day boom YouTube's gone so I I filed a
complaint and I request an emergency
injunction because my business is now at
risk and all of my employees could be
out of work unless this is reversed you
think it's likely a judge would say
reverse this until we can hear the case
probably probably they would probably
issue you know you'd probably win your
injunction given the nature of the law
and then then right once you win your
injunction they have to let you keep
your account until I would assume until
until it's adjudicated now then they say
but section 230 grants us this immunity
right let's say that the so who would
hear that case would it go to a federal
court then so I mean they could so it
depends I mean if they could probably
remove it to federal court right like
it's a there's enough money at issue
that would be what's called diversity
jurisdiction so yeah two bases of
federal court jurisdiction this is one
out one else learned their first day of
civil procedure okay uh two bases of
federal court jurisdiction either has to
be a federal question meaning it's a
federal you're suing under a federal law
or there's diversity jurisdiction which
means the parties are from different
states and there's at least 75 000 at
issue so this would be a state law so it
wouldn't be a probably wouldn't be a
federal question although they might
make a First Amendment claim I'm not
exactly I'd have to reread my work to
think about how that would work but it
certainly diverse so they could remove
it into federal court in Texas so let's
say in the federal court the the judge
hears it and says
I uh I I I understand section 230 but we
have a free speech issue where the first
amendment is supposed to protect the
rights of the individual and if Texas is
protecting the speech rights the First
Amendment can't supersede that so I rule
in favor of the complaintant right right
let's they sue because the Supreme Court
I'd imagine if if it goes it could
potentially well there's there's I I'd
actually have to think about whether or
not they'd have the right to appeal at
that point if you've had an injunction
if you have an injunction granted I
think you probably would have the right
to appeal that right away so let's say
YouTube then appeals you you'd appeal
that to the federal appeals court so
that would be the fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals
um then they would you know have a
fairly you know fairly quick hearing on
the injunction
um and then if they lose their they can
appeal so let's say they agree with you
and then they then YouTube appeals again
then it goes to Supreme Court yeah
Supreme Court they would they would they
would be applying for a stay of the
injunction now here's my final question
if the Supreme Court agrees with me in
that case would it impact the rest of
the country depends on how they wrote
the opinion right so if they write it in
an unpublished or non-presidential it
wouldn't but they could easily just as
easily write a presidential opinion on
the injunction if they wanted to and
then that would be binding law why would
they do one or the other uh sometimes
they they don't like putting out
presidential opinions if it's like a
very new issue they kind of want to let
lower courts handle it and like get more
reasoned opinions also in a rush they
don't like putting out uh because the
part of the thing is they're whenever
they make a rule it affects everyone
everything a variety different body laws
so oftentimes like when they're forced
to issue a ruling or an opinion on kind
of short notice because it's an
injunction they are reluctant to make it
like presidential so there are reasons
you know they want so whenever
something's presidential they want to be
careful and give it full review so
there's some reason you know in a in a
very very emergency circumstance they
might issue like a non-presidential
opinion it seems it seems tough though
it seems like the likelihood throughout
the tech the first the Texas judge
probably gonna side with you because the
Texas law says you can't do this but
then they're going to kick it to a
federal court
and then you have what the first federal
judge the Appellate and then the Supreme
Court yeah and I mean probably wouldn't
even you know the I'm not sure the state
judge might grant you that immediate
temporary restraining order before the
case is removed to Federal Court could
the federal judge say I want to hear it
state state law stands uh federal judge
could I mean the federal judge could
maybe say there's not even a federal
court I mean it's possible there's not
jurisdiction probably not the federal
judge would have to rule on the
injunction they could say uh for what
they could they could disagree right
they could say First Amendment doesn't
apply we're denying your injunction then
you could appeal
um or vice versa they could they could
go either way interesting so basically
Texas is granting you the right to this
platform to speak and this the federal
government would have to deny you that
right right exactly which is sort of and
there and there's precedent in different
contexts where not not in the tech
context but it's like in the union stuff
there's some there were some Supreme
Court case where the Supreme Court said
something like if a federal law preempts
a state right that grants a right to
speak that's a First Amendment issue and
there's a First Amendment prohibition
against that I wonder if if you were
suing YouTube for instance in Texas but
if YouTube's like a Delaware Corporation
then with that odd and you were in Texas
would that didn't automatically be
across state lines and immediately
become a federal depends so this is
another classic 1l civil procedure issue
which is a corporation is located in its
principal place of business in its place
of incorporation for diversity purposes
so Google's a you know primary place of
business is California Delaware
Corporation so if you are a resident of
either Delaware or California it would
diversity jurisdiction wouldn't be
available but if you were a resident of
Texas it would
man I think there's an easier solution
to this
I think Ian you were saying in three
months we can have this thing up and
running that was one person mentioned
that if we had 10 dedicated full-time
developers
that's like Optimal Pie in the Sky I
think three months but yeah something I
mean within the year for sure I would
imagine but what if we got like a
hundred you know open source Community
active Communication in a Discord server
it would be good and we're getting close
to that but there are diminishing
returns when people code over each other
and forking yeah too many cooks in the
kitchen so you wanna you wanna crack
team of like experts and Specialists so
what what I want to do is I want to make
it there's one big thing that makes
YouTube dominant and that's you make
money on YouTube there's a reason why
people don't use these other platforms
people get banned from YouTube and
they'll say okay fine I'll now we'll go
to minds.com but you make money on
YouTube now mines was smart about this
and they implemented a way to make money
on mines as well and the tokens actually
worth like three bucks now so yeah so
I've I haven't uh you know all my videos
automatically post on mines and
everything
but for most people they need to make
money so we want to make a way that you
can have an open source piece of
software free for everyone that makes it
very easy to install a website
you buy server space boom you install it
it's a functioning website where you can
easily post things WordPress already
makes it particularly easy so we're also
going to provide instructions and for
people because there's some you know
learning curve But it includes
subscription functionality so that
somebody can you can easily plug in if
you're using PayPal stripe or some other
you know eCommerce platform
then you have a members only so you can
isn't ghost doing something like this
because it's this sounds similar to
substack but ghost I think except this
is going to be you on your server with
your domain however you do it you own it
and no one can ban you but yourself
that's ghost I'm pretty sure I don't
know if you guys are familiar with the
most I'm gonna look them up though yeah
it exists yeah I think it might exist
already so you like drop drop it onto
your server and boom and then you got it
right right good like because I don't
know if you know Balaji uh srinivasan he
wrote about this right he was like
writing about like how you know after
Twitter censorship how do you do this
and he was like there's a sub stack is
still centralized right substance but
ghost is like something you implement on
your own what the website is uh I think
let me see because if I Google search
ghost I'm not going to find it yeah
not that hard but but listen listen
there's one other thing maybe they've
added this uh ghost.org if you want to
find that we we want to add a networking
functionality because the next big thing
about YouTube is that it markets you for
you
instead of buying marketing like a
traditional show if YouTube likes you
and thinks they'll make money off you
they'll start promoting your work so
what we want to add to these websites is
a networking section that's that's part
of the package now you'll have on your
site the ability to remove certain
people so they won't appear on your site
certain words phrases or things it's
your choice but it's your website so
then if I go to if someone goes
simcast.com
then this software allows people to
comment be users it's connected to the
fediverse so the networking section
functions like chat rooms or Twitter but
then they can also see recommended shows
that are very similar based on keywords
so it'll be like human events and you
know Carl Benjamin Lotus Eaters podcast
and then they'll be like oh cool and
they can get that recommendation feed
like they would on any other platform
but it's a decentralized network of
people just running these sites I was
just thinking a cool feature would be if
you opted in for your site to be found
on other sites then Tim could put my
site on his site and if someone found me
through Tim's site Tim would get five
percent of the revenue so you would be
able to opt into that it's not ghost
ghost is a free trial service sign up
it's like you get 14 days free trial I'm
talking about we would give you there's
like a plug-in oh it's like free it's
just totally free absolutely free for
everybody and you own it 100 it's open
source code it's just free to use when
you open it boom all of a sudden your
website has like a post section for you
you log in you just like click post like
you would be on Twitter or whatever
you've upload a video and then you can
click a lock button and lock it and say
five dollar members only and then people
can click become a member you'll need
your own accounts maybe PayPal bans you
maybe stripe bans you maybe your domain
bans you well those are other services
you can't get around but there won't be
a patreon CEO who bans you there won't
be a jack Conte who bans you and then in
or uh in order to you see a CEO of
patreon in order to then network with
other people it's in the fediverse the
federal verse for people don't know is
basically like a Twitter protocol where
different servers can communicate with
each other so you could follow someone
on gab but also see them on a different
server a different website all out all
together
so then we basically create
probably the way it should be
if we do that we don't need section 230.
that's true I mean I really would like
to create a world where we just that
these people are irrelevant right like I
think that's the end goal and I mean I'm
I'm all for it I'm not a tech guy I
don't know Tech I know law and so I'm
just like okay how do I use how do we
change the law to solve the problem
that's my you know that's my role I hope
you guys canceled via Tech I think you
can't legislate away every problem
that's for sure that's true but I mean
you know some people I I still have a
pro like people underestimate how
effective law can be solving at
particular types of problems you know I
mean we've we've got a lot of there's a
lot of background for how to solve
common carrier type problems and
discrimination type problems I mean
that's what that's the whole thing
Clarence Thomas wrote about you know he
wrote you know went through you can make
big Tech comic carrier you can make them
have public accommodation laws and and
then you create private rights of action
like you don't you don't need a
bureaucracy to solve civil rights like
you literally can just do it through
people litigating very briefly how do
you feel about legislating gun rights
like saying limiting people's gun rights
when there are 3D printers that can
print those weapons and see secret I
mean I I basically think I'm a
constitutionalist on that I think you
know Heller is right we shouldn't you
know guns that are in common you
shouldn't be regulated uh I think
you know I mean I'm not a I guess I
wouldn't say I'm an absolutist in the
sense that I think all current gun laws
are unlawful or something via the Second
Amendment because I think even at the
time of the founding there were some
some restrictions out there and I think
I mean I remember there was some stuff
you were saying about like for example I
think it's okay to prohibit like violent
felons from owning guns right like I I'm
okay with that one I disagree with it
what gets me is when they try and say
it's illegal to have this kind of gun
but then it can be 3D printed in
someone's basement like you can't yeah
you can't back that like you can't
enforce that loss so yeah it's bad to
have laws that are unenforceable in
general I don't like unenforceable laws
um but you know I mean I saw you were
like you were going through the Dante
right case and be like that person
shouldn't have been arrested or whatever
for the country well but there was also
the aggravated robbery which is a
different story right well I mean but
yeah like my view is okay so the guy
gets out you know he's he's arrested for
aggravated robbery and indicted in trial
dates in two years well we want to give
him bail okay but he's been indicted for
aggravated robbery like I think it's a
reasonable condition of bail that you
not possess a firearm at that point yeah
I agree right right right my position is
after they get out of prison and we're
like you've pegged it to society they
get their rights back
I I think I think that's more defensible
but I still I'm still okay with laws
that say like certain you know violent
felonies if you committed a violent
felony you you forfeit that right in the
same way that you forfeit a voting right
I think you should have the right to
vote
like if you're in prison maybe not uh if
you're in prison you obviously don't get
a gun but if you're out like it I I just
don't like the idea of second-class
citizens for any reason I agree you you
people have to be brought back in and we
have to give people the opportunity
because when the problem with these
felony laws I'll tell you a story I I
worked at this uh I worked at a smoothie
shop once and this this woman who worked
there apparently was like
telling so I I overheard this so I could
be wrong it's been like 15 years a woman
applied for a job
and
on the application she said that she was
a felon and her felony she explained it
was that she was arrested for sleeping
in an airport she was there she
overstayed her ticket and she remained
in the airport so they eventually
arrested her with a felony for being in
an airport without a ticket something
like that and then they gloated about
how they would not hire her and they
were like as if we would hire that
person and I'm like she's trying to work
a minimum wage job selling smoothies
dude yeah no I mean that's a different
actually a different issue where I'm
like totally okay with certain
government programs so like subsidize
the hiring of people it's it's it's not
it's not necessarily what you know but
just what I mean I'm just saying if
someone knows no matter what I do I am
going to be a second class citizen why
would I yeah why would they bother
reforming themselves or trying to come
back into society and doing better they
can't travel they can't you know have a
weapon they can't defend themselves they
can't vote they're not they're not no
taxation without representation I don't
care if you've come if you're familiar
if you're if you're out of jail if the
judge says your punishment for doing
this will be 10 years then after the 10
years then we're like welcome back
now don't do it again and you'll enjoy
the fruits of American citizenship but
if you're a second class citizen you're
much more likely in my opinion to do it
again I agree so then you have more
people in jail
because you view yourself as an outsider
at that point you're like I'm not a part
of your system I'll do what I want and
if you can't get a job then it's you
know I mean that seems I mean I would
focus on the job part I just don't think
you're entitled to vote at that point I
don't think that I mean I'm also more of
a utilitarian when it comes to voting I
don't like you know then I'll say this
shall not be infringed
yeah but shall not kill should 13 year
olds 13 year olds build up be allowed to
buy guns no shall not be infringed
in in in this in 1789 were there 15 year
olds who owned their own property and
were you know running I mean like there
are still those possession laws right
for example Rittenhouse I mean he like
I'm pretty sure I know they're trying to
prosecute him for unlawful possession of
that firearm but my reading of the law
says it was lawful yeah yeah I've I've
heard some other experts talk about this
now let me clarify too I'm actually just
giving a very harsh interpretation of 2A
I don't think 13 year olds should be
allowed to buy guns or have guns I think
there should be
um it is difficult though and the reason
I say this is back then you know way
back when the the age limits were much
lower for a lot of things we've moved
them up repeatedly 18. it was it was so
we set it at 16 then it's 18. now it's
21 they're trying to make it 21 in some
places eventually it'll be 30.
eventually it'll be 35. so the champion
I non-ironically think we should raise
the voting age to 30.
is there a constitutional amendment that
says the right to voting shall not be
infringed for any persons in the United
States
I don't think so there's a there was
there was a late Constitutional
Amendment that reduced the I think the
voting age to 18 for everybody there
there are I think three three amendments
it's voting age uh women and um on Race
I believe yeah so I mean we just need to
revise that one that's made at 18 just
might go we're not going to get that
that that uh Constitutional Amendment
anytime soon yeah I was so excited
um thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time